Now it's time
for tonight's #HashtagWars.
Let's begin.
-(cheering, applause)
-It's time...
In this time of unparalleled
political divisiveness,
America has finally found a hero
it can rally behind.
I'm speaking, of course,
about undecided debate attendee
and living Pringles mascot
Ken Bone.
-(cheering, applause) -My new
favorite person in the universe.
Even Twitter's Moments
feature, uh...
flat-out said, quote,
"Ken Bone is
a national treasure."
Hyperbole?
I don't think so!
This guy is right up there
with Yellowstone National Park
and using donuts
as hamburger buns.
I mean... check out
Ken's Facebook page,
where it turns out
he also plays Pokémon GO,
but he plays as Obi-Wan Kenboni.
(laughter)
I love you, Ken!
(applause)
(grunts)
I hope your Team Mystic, Ken,
but cut the red sweater--
I think you might be Team Valor.
That's okay. We can cross
barriers and still be friends.
Uh... in fact, he's taking on
legendary status.
Like some kind of folk hero.
♪
♪ Ken Bone.
(laughter, applause)
-(cheering)
-Oh. How convenient.
We have a folk hero here.
So in honor of this
sensible Paul Bunyan,
tonight's hashtag is
#KenBoneFacts. #KenBoneFacts.
Examples might be:
Ken Bone is the fraternal twin
-of every NFL assistant coach,
and... -(laughter)
Ken Bone doesn't give
mustache rides,
he gives mustache journeys.
(laughter, whooping, applause)
And here to help us out
with this game,
all the way from his home
in Lizard's Thicket,
the thrice-divorced
singer-songwriter,
Slim Whiteman is here!
(cheering, applause)
MAN:
Yeah!
♪ Ken Bone.
All right, perfect.
Thank you very much.
So I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock, and begin.
-Kurt.
-Uh...
Ken Bone owns over 1,000 DVD's,
but they're all
of the movie Sully.
-All right.
-(laughter)
♪ Ken Bone.
-All right.
-(applause, whooping)
-Brian Posehn.
-Ken Bone's sleep apnea machine
gets cable. -All right.
♪ Ken Bone
HARDWICK:
Kurt.
Ken Bone's sweater isn't red,
it just blushes
when he wears it.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
(cheering, applause)
Brian Posehn.
When Ken Bone is stuck in
traffic,
the "N" word he yells is nutmeg.
(Hardwick laughing)